hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is the newest Android flagship
phone from LG
it's the g3 so it's the successor to the
LG g2 which was really nice but it had
its flaws and this new phone here is out
to compete with the galaxy s5 and the
HTC One and others so what does it bring
well first of all I've done two previous
videos on this phone one right before it
actually came out it was actually an
exclusive video and mkbhd first hands-on
with this new phone before you saw it
anywhere else and my impressions were
pretty positive and then a second video
all about its display because if you
haven't already heard this phone's
display matches the highest resolution
ever in any phone at 2560 by 1440 or
more than 530 pixels per inch
so really what we're out here to find
out is if packing all those pixels has a
negative effect on two of the most
important things to consider in a new
smartphone the battery life and the
performance I'll get into that very
shortly but really we've already seen
that this is a very handsome phone
that's the first thing that struck me
about it is plastic yes but with this
brush metal looking finish it kind of
fakes a metal look but it keeps the
phone much lighter by using plastic and
it has a curved back that fits in your
hand pretty nicely so I actually like
the way it feels in the hand and because
of this back button placement you
actually get to hold the phone just a
little bit differently than other phones
that put the buttons on the side on the
top and it's actually super quick and
easy to get used to it seems weird at
first but it's actually really intuitive
after just a couple of hours of using
the phone and the back buttons here are
also shortcuts when the screen is asleep
so holding the volume button up will
quickly open your Notes app or holding
the volume button down will quickly open
your camera app from asleep would have
been even nicer if I could change these
shortcuts though because I never really
use LG's Notes app but they're there
so button placement keeps the phone
profile thin keeps the bezels really
thin and sexy it's still a big phone
though don't get me wrong it is compact
for a phone of its size it's a big 5.5
inch display but with the thin bezels
but still most high-end phones have a 5
inch or 5.1 inch display so this is
still going to be a very big phone for a
lot of people so the display you can
watch my original video about its
sharpness and resolution and you'll
basically see that it's insanely sharp
it's significantly sharper than a 1080p
display or even an iPhone with its sub
720p display and it does look pretty
great even if the colors are a little
bit off the contrast ratio is not so
great the white balance is questionable
you know a lot of the other aspects of
the display aren't really all that great
it looks a little bit pink or a little
bit warm to me when compared to an HTC
One but overall really anything that can
take advantage of this this sharpness is
a couple of years out I mean that isn't
much right now you know the resolution
is not going to make a huge difference
now because apps and games and
wallpapers don't take advantage of it
yet but I would expect to see a lot more
quad HD phone start to come out in the
second half of this year and next year
and then we'll start to see a lot more
apps that will take advantage of the
sharpness but right now it's just kind
of a spec line to get you to look at the
phone and pay attention to it but it's a
good-looking phone anyway and I really
get this this idea I had this idea to go
out and ask people if they could tell
the difference between this LG g3 s
display and maybe another 5.5 inch
display and another phone that's 1080p
but I have a feeling a lot of people
would like the g3 anyway just because of
how thin the bezels look it just looks
better than a lot of other phones I mean
you could have given me a 1080p display
here with this thin of a bezel and I'd
probably still be just as happy with it
and it all comes down to the fact that
this phone's design happens to be well
just really attractive around the back
you have this removable back so you
reveal here a 3000 milliamp hour battery
and a micro SD card slot for those of
you who want to expand storage and with
battery life I was again impressed it
was actually excellent so there was
obviously concerns about whether or not
this display would have an impact on
battery life pushing all those pixels
taking a hit on the graphics but as far
as I can tell no my usage was always
pretty moderate to heavy and for the
first few days the battery life was
decent but then it got better especially
the standby time I feel like you could
go to sleep with 100% battery and wake
up with 99% and he'd be great and now it
lasts just as long on a charge as the
One m8 that I was raving about I had a
road trip the other day where I got four
and a half hours of screen on time which
is more than I've got
with plenty of other 1080p phones so I
really like the battery life on this one
plus the fact that it's removable that's
a big bonus for a lot of people now the
camera it's sporting also has some
pretty unique features too so the
software that LG threw in here it's
really really simple they're going after
a really simplified UI no real
fine-tuning controls you're not going to
get any manual modes in here but it is
outfitted with some neat modes where you
can change obviously the resolution and
you can change the size of the videos
you're taking up to 4k you can turn
stabilization on and off but you also
have this magic focus mode you have a
fist gesture selfie which lets you just
make a fist and then open it and it'll
start the countdown timer so you don't
actually have to touch your phone to
take a selfie I know it's it's a selfie
feature but whatever and then you have
laser autofocus and that is really
really great so laser autofocus on the
back of this phone you might have been
wondering what that last little port
does it actually fires a laser at the
thing you're taking a picture of and
then reflects it back and is able to
tell exactly how far away the subject is
focus the camera and take the picture
and that all happens extremely quickly
and so I'm really a big fan of laser
autofocus it does really well with
landscapes it does really well with
up-close subjects and macro stuff and
it's one of the fastest focusing cameras
I've used in a smartphone so props to LG
for that now another thing that we were
talking about was the performance of
this phone and again I found that it's
been pretty good if you check it out
versus another high-end phone with a
1080p display like the HTC One m8 or the
Galaxy s5 or something like that it
holds up pretty much exactly the same
the only tiny little thing I found which
is kind of ironic because I saw it in
another phone is a little bit of a delay
with the soft buttons but a lot of these
little minor things can be fixed with a
software update there were concerns
about the graphics being taking a hit
because of all these pixels I would say
I don't see anything the gaming is
exactly the same the opening and closing
apps is exactly the same the scrolling
the frame rates everything still looks
great so this is of course the LG scan
on top of android 4.4 kitkat
and it seems to perform really well and
the design is okay now a lot of people
are really gushing over this design I
just think it's okay it's definitely
better than the skin that was in the
lg g2 so I appreciate that improvement
but I'm of course you know how I feel
about Android skins already there are a
couple of things I would like to see
changed you can only really see maybe
two sometimes three notifications at
once before you have to scroll just
because of how much stuff is going on in
the notification bar the Settings app is
still pretty ugly and I think awful to
navigate it's been a while since the
skin phone did settings well and I think
most smartphones could really use it
overall to the Settings app and the
multitasking it's smart it makes a lot
of sense the pinch-to-zoom
to be able to see more or less apps at
the same time as smart but is this
really how you wanted it to look I'm not
sure that I really like the way it
appears but there's also plenty of other
interesting great stuff about this LG
skin one thing I love the LG keyboard is
really nice if you go into the keyboard
settings you can pick exactly how tall
it is when I first got the phone out the
box the keyboard was actually too small
for me despite it having a big display
but I had big hands I made the screen
and the keyboard bigger and now I love
that it has been the number pad
available all the time it's great I also
love that the enhanced clipboard feature
is so smart I think every phone should
adopt something like this it remembers
multiple things that you can copy
multiple screenshots multiple things
that you want to paste and whenever you
hold down to start to try to pay
something it'll ask you which thing you
want to paste it's very very useful also
LG has a couple of these notices these
smart cards which I thought were pretty
funny I don't know why I found them so
funny that you could just go to Google
now for the weather but it always felt
the need to give me a long sentence
about how the day was going to go so
that was nice and there's plenty of
other features that LG's worked on
there's the dual window for multitasking
there's a knock code for unlocking your
phone I stopped using it but it is
pretty neat so tons of stuff like that
the 1 amp speaker on the back of this
phone it's supposed to be amplified it's
supposed to be special it's not special
I mean it's kind of loud a little bit
but it's really kind of just like any
other back facing speaker phone I also
wish the notification LED was a little
bigger just because I've been messing
with a lot of phones recently that it's
way brighter on but overall really you
got to admit the g3 is a complete
package there are a lot of great things
about this phone if you're coming from a
g2 you're going to like a lot of the
improvements especially in the software
department and you just can't say no to
that display when you're future-proof
like that the one weird thing that I
found was it tends to heat up a little
bit I have screenshots of times where it
would tell me I can't brighten the phone
anymore because if I do it'll overheat
and it basically doesn't want me to so
it's trying to cool the phone down by
limiting how bright I can make the
display and one time I was navigating in
Google Maps and it actually threatened
to basically say it's going to turn off
soon if you don't cool this phone down
so sometimes it does heat up a little
bit more than other phones I've used I
haven't gotten that notice on other
phones but other than that I got to love
it so bottom line is I am really a fan
of what I'm seeing on the lg g3 and I
really like it now if you'd asked me
what I thought the best phones of 2014
would be at the beginning of this year I
might have left the LG g3 off the list
just because I wasn't a huge fan of the
g2 I wasn't a fan of LG skin not as much
as some other people anyway so I
probably would have gone straight to the
Galaxy series and the note series and
the HTC One but now that this is out and
now that we know everything we know
about it it's clearly easily one of the
best phones that's come out this year if
not the best especially because of the
display so again let me know what you
guys think of this LG g3 that's been it
for this full video review thank you for
watching and if you have any other
questions or comments about it feel free
to drop those in the comments section
below so I can answer them and talk to
you guys again thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
bass
you